what's going on guys this is Rob and
welcome to our final video as part of
time runs out now what I'm hoping is
that as we progress to this video that
while we're going to find that pretty
much everything ends because of the fact
that Marvel has crammed so much stuff
into this I'm hoping that by the time
this video is finished that you'll
understand exactly the way everything is
coming to an end the way it is at the
universe or I guess the multiverse is
collapsing but what I've also done is
I've basically organized this video in a
way to where I'm hoping that it won't be
too oversaturated that everything will
make sense to you guys and so if you
recall in our last video we had talked
about how name of the Submariner Thanos
and the rest of the cabal have been left
to die on an alternate earth during an
incursion with the Ultimate Universe and
that they were actually able to escape
that incursion by jumping into the
ultimate universe and the planet that
was getting ready to crash into the
ultimate universe was destroyed by the
ultimate version of Reed Richards and so
what we find here is that alongside Reed
Richards and Nick Fury from the ultimate
universe the cabal basically feed them
these half-truths they tell them tell
them basically what it is it needs to be
said in order for the ultimate the
ultimat group to go against the main
earth-616 continuity when realizing that
the final incursion is going to take
place between the two that the ultimate
universe is going to crash into the main
earth universe and that unless one of
the earth so destroyed they're both
going to be annihilated entirely and so
what happens is that the ultimate
universe basically begins to make battle
formations they begin to prepare to
attack the main earth universe now from
here what we do is we pick up with the
multiversal Avengers now again we
discuss in the last video that with
Captain America hunting down the
Illuminati and the Illuminati themselves
being on the run there wasn't really
anyone focusing on a way to end the
incursions or even trying to keep the
peace on the planet Earth and so what
sunspot did is he launched his own
Avengers team with the intention of
sending half the team into the
multiverse to try to find a way to stop
the incursions and the other half
staying on earth as a way to keep the
peace and so what we also discussed here
was that when the group that was sent
into the multiverse came across dr.
strange that they combined forces and
they split into two groups the first
group was led
by dr. strange and they were designed to
basically try to find a way to track
down or boom along the person who was
presumably responsible for the death or
I guess the the death of a universe that
started the whole chain reaction that
led to the incursions in the first place
and the second group would basically go
and try to find a way to end the
incursions proper which of course this
group was led by Odin's son and so what
we find here is that when Thor Odin's
son and this group eventually come
across the beyonders and cells that
while there's a little bit of a
discussion here that the Thor Odinson
and his crew basically attacked the
beyonders and when they do the beyonders
eradicate Thor Odinson s group entirely
they kill Hyperion they kill Odin son
they kill star brand they kill night
Mass they kill everyone like the entire
multiversal of interest group is now
gone and so what we do here is we jump
to Doctor Strange
now what Doctor Strange or what happens
with him is he actually discovers that
we're boom awal is none other than
Doctor Doom
now what we find is that in a previous
video if you recall we had talked about
how when the incursians had first
started on the planet Earth that Doctor
Doom had basically found a way to map
the multiversal Network and like muntin
like most everybody else doctor dooms
goal was to find a way to either find
the source point of the incursians and
take that power for himself or the
simply end the incursions and there
entirely and so what had happened is
that dr. doom and molecule man had
basically gone on this journey and what
happens is that dr. doom basically
explains to Doctor Strange
everything that's been happening what
dr. doom says is that in the multiverse
itself there are a multiple a multitude
of variations of different characters
that with dr. doom for example and one
reality he may have gained his powers a
different way they needed in the main
earth-616 reality that in one reality
dr. doom may be a super hero instead of
a instead of a super villain and one
reality Doctor Doom may have no powers
at all but that with molecule man it's
not this way with molecule man he exists
the same in every single reality that
his past is the exact same he gained his
powers the exact same and then this was
actually an experiment by the beyonders
what the be honors wanted to do is they
wanted to create a being who was so
incredibly powerful that that beings
destruction would result in the
destruction of the universe itself
and then they want to take that being
and put one version of him and
every single reality and then kill them
all at one time
effectively destroying all the
multiverse at the same time and so once
dr. doom had realized this what he did
or at least what he was tasked to do by
molecule man was to destroy or kill
every version of molecule man and the
multiverse and so with the first
molecule man that he killed in an
alternate reality it resulted in the
destruction of that reality and that's
what started the incursions happening
that's what caused everything to take
place and so the result was that as
Doctor Doom was going through and
killing all these different versions of
molecule man he was effectively speeding
up the incursions he was causing the
death of the universe to happen or the
death of the multiverse to happen at a
much faster pace than it normally would
now eventually there came a time when
the beyonders began to take notice of
what was happening they began to realize
that somebody was going through and
killing molecule man and so as a result
they basically took to the multiverse to
find out who this person was and to end
this person to destroy this person and
so it's at this point that we jump to
Hank him and the reason why is because
we find out what the beyonders were
doing while they were in the multiverse
trying to find the person who was
killing molecule man when hank pym 'no
Strava was sent to travel into the
multiverse and what i mean here is that
when captain america first began hunting
down the Illuminati that Reed Richards
sent Hank Pym into the multiverse to
also be someone who could try to find a
way to stop the incursions and that
while Reed rich I'm sorry well hank pym
had come across all these different
alternate realities that ultimately he
discovered or he stumbled upon the
beyonders as they were annihilating the
Celestials and an alternate reality now
once those Celestials were destroyed
then we found the cosmic entity stepped
in that infinity Lord order master chaos
the in-betweener
eternity itself they had all stepped in
but they had all been destroyed by the
beyonders equally in the same way that
the Celestials had been destroyed and so
the result here was that while all these
different versions of Celestials like
cosmic entities and all these realities
are being killed this ultimately drew
the attention of the Living Tribunal and
so the Living Tribunal up here Dazz the
being that's designed to serve the
purpose of I guess making ensuring
balance exists and the multiverse the
Living Tribunal up here to basically
just to stop and destroy the beyonders
but what is up happening here is the
beyonders use their combined power and
they destroy the living
tribunal and so at this point in the
marvel and Marvel continuity in terms of
the entire multiverse there are no
multiversal entities the only one we
know of is the one above all and we
don't know what's going on with that
character we don't know if that
character exists we don't know if that
character is so far beyond the power of
the beyonders that the one above all
doesn't care what's taking place we
don't know if the one above all was
previously destroyed by the beyonders
these are things that we don't
understand here all we know is that the
B honours have wiped out the Living
Tribunal and that there are no more
cosmic entities anywhere in the
multiverse and so what we do here is we
pick up with the conclusion of this
story as Hank M's telling it to the
Illuminati and so Captain America
basically stands down Captain America
says that at this point the focus needs
to be on how to survive the collapse of
the multiverse and that the conflict
between himself and the Illuminati is
basically a very minor thing in
comparison to what's going on here but
what Captain America also realizes is a
Tony Stark knew all along that this
could not be stopped but since the very
beginning of the incursions Tony Stark
knew that there was nothing that could
be done to Mb incursions and so on sort
of this in this I guess state of rage so
to speak
Captain America basically takes to Tony
Stark now in truth this is really just
Marvel kind of giving us this last
conflict this last hurrah between Tony
Stark and Captain America a conflict
that in truth had really been building
since the end of Civil War but the fact
remains here that with Tony Stark and
Captain America fighting one another
while the two of them are going at it
and while Tony Stark is eventually made
to submit and the midst of their
conflict what we find is that the
Ultimate Universe begins its invasion of
the main Marvel Universe and so at this
point this ends our story with time runs
out we actually won't find out what
happens next and show Secret Wars number
one which comes out on Wednesday with
that being said I hope this video made
sense I know it was a lot to take in but
Marvel crammed a lot of stuff into a
very short amount of time so yeah I hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you did
let me know and I will catch you guys
later peace